é bom dia eu o sinto que eu trago pra
aqui é um exercício relativamente
simples mas é uma coisa que nós estamos
habituados a universidade quer fazer
estímulos que são afinal a ponta de um
grande iceberg me disse isso é sobre
esta pergunta para onde vai a economia
portuguesa
esta é uma pergunta que muita gente
treinamento muitos nós temos momentos e
ela pergunta importante porque muita
gente importante também têm na mente e
ele acha é tão importante quanto a mim
que muita gente importante usa pra
reduzir argumentos sobre a situação
económica portuguesa e também sobre
aquilo que deve ser feito
a minha questão é que está o que eu
trago pra que tal ponto 20 e é uma
questão do que decorre do meu
conhecimento da economia portuguesa
entrou determinada perspectiva que é da
história econômica a questão que terá
que receber temer se esta pergunta vale
a pena se vale a pena estarmos sempre
tratados estão preocupados com esta
pergunta a uma forma na primeira forma é
que podemos utilizar é para dar uma
primeira resposta é esta pergunta
globalização globalização não é uma
palavra vai de todo inclusivamente a
alma consegue pode ser codificado e nós
tivemos que não valorização hoje através
dessa qualificação através de vários
tipos de análises podem ser
quantificados qualificada
enfim rotativas nós sabemos que a
globalização hoje é melhor que há 20
anos a 30 40 anos
ora está em significado que é que as
economias nacionais cada vez mais tão
dependente de algumas coisas que
acontecem fora das suas fronteiras por
tanque e isto é produzir um pouco
absurdo mas prevê dada já que o enfoque
aquilo que eu quero fazer aqui logo
falar sobre a minha portuguesa e implica
falar sobre o seu
na globalização e portanto é pergunta
para onde vai caminhar portuguesa não é
substancialmente diferente da pergunta
para onde vai a globalização e aqui nós
já vemos que realmente é uma pergunta
que deixa algo é desejar
ainda mais porque com esta globalização
que não é uma palavra vai repeti embora
seja uma palavra muitas vezes usava
nomeadamente usava mesmo ela te não é vã
a globalização faz com que seja cada vez
mais difícil do filho uma economia
nacional tem as suas interdependências
entre essa e carminho resto do mundo não
é o bastante mas não sabemos muito bem o
que é se caminha nacional tanto que eu
trago aqui em um fundo esta questão é
demandado da pergunta para onde vai a
economia portuguesa e nota em que isto é
perspectiva de alguém que vem da
história e nome que está preocupado com
a forma como nós analisamos encaminha
portuguesa de frutas nós fazemos sobre a
economia portuguesa e desce com as
implicações políticas dessa forma daniel
execramento portuguesa com as
implicações políticas nós fazemos este
tipo de perguntas
vamos então ver se eu consigo convencer
nos que esta não é uma grande pergunta
pra isso vamos olhar para as costas que
ela dá um pessimistas e otimistas os
pessimistas normalmente mais simpático
11 tempo vivemos num país em que o
pessimismo é um pouco mais alargado do
que outros países mais avançados
pessimismo que pediu à prefeitura maior
pessimismo na suíça a criar perigo por
causa dos níveis diferenciados
desenvolvimento econômico que a tensão
tem muitos anos não são de ontem enviar
15 dias e nós através da perspectiva dos
pessimistas nós começamos a perceber que
as coisas não são assim tão simples e
através da perspectiva otimista então
conseguimos ver que realmente é
perguntas carvão leva muito longe
pessimistas na nossa história a há muito
tempo a 17
o século 19 que é especialista no
pessimismo no pessimismo na opinião
pública
viajo século 19 certo no debate público
é o século 19 certo modo certo modo é
portugal e no resto da europa e é o
século da invenção do ato público também
é natural que seja uma altura em que
estas coisas apareçam com mais evidência
temos é que um grupo de grandes
pessimistas famosos pessimistas
vestígios de vida finais século 19
núcleos de idade esta filosofia que nós
olhamos prêmios são todos nomes
conhecidos e nós disso aposta nos tons
bege que aos 77
seguramente não foram e aos próprios ver
city pela vida ao contrário e
implementar aqui um paradoxo eles
venceram de vida por causa daquilo que
estava a acontecer que final eu vi o
número é tão pessimista de entre aos das
várias coisas que o sindicel de que
essas queiroz oliveira martins tudo
gente com grande valor com grande mérito
da questão não é essa
está um pouquinho com a mia tenta várias
coisas que os disseram nos que esta esta
é uma frase que diz respeito a uma
afirmação que diz respeito a uma crise
em portugal porque portugal pessoa em
finais do século 19 uma crise vai
conhecida está continuada com o que
esteve condicionada com o ultimato em
1890 que uma crise financeira
temos uma crise financeira associada em
1991 e credo em 1892 portugal do corot
bancarrota parcial
aliás a história económica que estamos a
dizer que nem fumar escolha que fazer
que esperar portugal tem tropeçado crise
igualmente macho obviamente mas nelas
nunca nos faltaram nem homens de valor e
quer até nem é o crédito
hoje não temos dinheiro também não podia
27 anos para fixarmos nesta situação
porque elas também é o nós abrimos as
provisões os mais os média e vemos
muitas vezes esse tipo de afirmação hoje
crédito não temos dinheiro também não
lhe a gente foi repetindo aquela famosa
frase não à dinheiro qual das três
palavras não percebe pelo bem do estado
não tem e homens não usar
acho que a ação proposta pela sombra
pela política
isto é algo bastante recorrente era algo
bastante no século 19 e é isso que está
a acontecer outra vez mas é que esta
parte que é mais importante quanto a mim
de sorte que esta crise parece pior e
sem cura
toda a gente tem sempre razão
não há nada a fazer é mesmo assim e
ainda vai ficar assim que o bar
totalmente site e estas pessoas
antes disso quem disse isso foi um dos
maiores intelectuais do século 19
eça de queirós não desmerecem 45 vindo
de toda a história em portugal mas eu
tinha razão estar nesses estados por na
altura também se falava do famigerado
prédio na altura nos prender a diferença
nas taxas de juro da dívida do estado
português relativamente à grã bretanha
onde os prédios ativamente a manha e na
verdade neste período em que essa
queiroz e os vestígios de vida
falavam e pensavam sobre a situação do
país
os prédios estava tinha atingido os
valores muito altos
e assim continuou durante algum tempo e
até meados da década seguinte até 1905
por razões que é fácil de entender mas
que agora não interessam que a equipe
está sempre alguma razão mas o que
estava a acontecer com a economia
portuguesa e para onde foi pra mim
portuguesa e que a vantagem da história
e por isso é que ela é é instrumento
utilizado a história percebemos o
presente
eventualmente inclusivamente pensarmos
no futuro não para o primeiro obviamente
a vantagem da história que sempre
conhecemos o futuro para certo nós temos
um conhecimento sobre a evolução da
economia portuguesa naquela altura e
surpresa no tempo dessa poderosa que o
quadro acho que é correspondente àquela
altura em que os prédios gigantes no
tempo de eça de queirós e caminhos
portuguesa estava a crescer
moderadamente
afinal para casa um portugal é um país
de preferir o país ainda prefiro o pai
toda primeiro painel segue a nova que
chegou nada mesmo
mas depois foi para um crescimento que
não tinha acontecido anteriormente
legislativamente rápido assim
a primeira guerra mundial portugal teve
um crescimento econômico que não foi que
foi dos melhores na europa era muito
difícil realmente responder esta
pergunta para onde vai caminhar
portuguesa no século 19 e neste momento
nós sabemos porque todos sabemos o que
aconteceu é seguir em um outro otimismo
outro pessimista e este pessimista foi o
esquilo ao caso está foi escrito no
google que até é aquilo que aconteceu
foi a pessoa mais conhecida
o pessimista mais preciso nas questões
da economia portuguesa que nos diz isto
numa notícia que aparece com este
portugal será obrigado a desvalorizar
salários e preços e continua alguns
países do sul da europa como portugal ou
espanha aliás é uma certa contradição
vão ter desvalorização lares e os preços
nos próximos anos como consequência da
crise financeira
pronto vai com a minha empresa por aqui
atenção
precisamos ter muito cuidado assustadas
vamos ter que fazer espra que caminha
portuguesa não vá por aí espécie mista é
alguém que começa terá seguramente
ficará na história nas suas orações e
tem valor por isso que não haja dúvidas
quanto a isso é e vítor bento que disse
isto em 2010
aliás em 2010 muita gente muito pouca
gente teve outra ong caminho portuguesa
e nesse 150 já é um pouco a história
nestes últimos cinco anos nós
verificarmos que ninguém tenho para onde
ir ea economia portuguesa em 2010
isto não quer dizer que estas pessoas
não aceitaram entendemos ser enfim vagas
há enfim destinadas por que não
acertaram
não minha questão é que elas colocaram
mal a pergunta agora os otimistas ou
otimistas traga aqui otimistas de dois
tipos tipo 1 que são estes antigos em
1933 foi anunciado outro estava
encantado
foi pública o governo publicou este este
mapa para mostrar para um dia a
sociedade a política à economia
portuguesa nos anos vindouros que era
este império que ia para lá em da europa
este vasto império
nós hoje gastar reconhecemos o futuro
sabemos que dificilmente consegue fazer
uma conta de coisas negativas e
positivas e em geral que mentem este
império e outros empenhos nos levem à
conclusão que tudo valeu a pena é
evidente que essa conta é difícil de
fazer porque não sabemos o que teria
acontecido disse
mas é muito peso que facilmente chegamos
a uma conclusão que o sálvio não terá
sido assim tão positivo esta promessa de
praia onde ia o futuro é final e acabou
por não se confirmar aos confirmou foi
com muito aquém das expectativas de quem
apresentou esta é a perspectiva é tão
otimista é que em termos de plataforma
continental
essa medalha é muito bom que o governo
está tudo esteja a lutar por isso e é
muito bom portugal ganhar conseguir isso
mas agora isso é prometido é nos
apresentado com uma promessa de um
futuro grandioso o futuro de portugal no
mar é outra vez um ateísmo bastante
grande inclusive momento em que este
mapa que replica o mapa do império que é
a plataforma continental dimensão da
plataforma continental comparava com a
dimensão de vários países europeus é uma
curiosidade nos parecem ter uma
presidenta
em três anos o que pensava é que entra a
política é que entra a política neste
país e nem pensem que estou mais um
pouco mais para o mate que acho que tem
que falar de um homem que tem sido
marginalizado porque precisamente nós
temos
muito chave é diferente nós tem estado a
passar e para mim é muito chava e é
precisamente nessa esfera em que parece
pergunta para onde vai a economia
portuguesa e este homem que é conhecido
internacionalmente como alguém que
trouxe um contributo fundamental ter
atingido o nome e não só como prêmios
para a solução do problema sem nome é
kaing se o que quem nos diz uma frase
muito muito conhecida mas ficou vai ser
recordada é que o longo prazo é um
enganador para os assuntos atuais
o para onde vai pra mim portuguesa uma
pergunta enganadora provas assuntos
atuais da economia portuguesa a longo
prazo
estamos todos mortos e shitake umas
pequenas é farkas música mistas
os economistas atribuem a si mesmo
tarefas não sou economista entretanto
esse mesmo tarefas com facilidade mole
inútil
mesmo em períodos tempestuosos prêmios
crise como o atual está publicado
escrito nos anos 20 em 1924 mesmo entre
wood tempo estudiosos
quando só nos conseguem dizer que depois
da tempestade passar
o mar voltará a ficar calma esta ideia
de pensar no futuro era é conhecer o
presente tem aqui uma boa intenção que
me ajuda é dizer que ela é uma grande
grande idéia era que ainda insistem que
é uma coisa importante não pensou só fez
também como na altura em que eu tento
fazer alguma coisa é seguir durante o
tratado de versalhes e e seguir à
primeira guerra mundial em que eu tento
fazer alguma coisa não foi ouvido por
tipo na altura o problema em questão era
saber para onde ir à europa onu nova
geografia da europa é nova geopolíticas
da europa e não consigo fazer nada mas
em 1944 em bretton woods foi ao evento o
secretário de estado do tesouro norte
americano e é que o teu recomendava foi
deram x6 simpson mas fundamentalmente
foi feito o que eu recomendo não esperou
pelo instante com o futuro olhamos para
a situação da economia internacional
o que é preciso fazer para recuperar os
equipamentos nacional e essa recuperação
é fundamental
daí pra mim internacional para recuperar
as economias nacionais brecha no dia 5
44 deu o mote com a sua ideia nota em
que quem escape de inglaterra europa em
um negócio axônio economia é uma
corrupção pensamento já é um homem só
como é evidente em 1947 fez um plano
acham que foi despejar dinheiro em cima
da economia internacional e muito
dinheiro 3% do pib norte-americano
durante vários anos em 1953
a dívida da alemanha foi perdoada pronto
vai caminhar o pai não interessa o que é
preciso sempre foi pra minha
internacional é o teu interesse e eu foi
ouvido em conclusão a pergunta para onde
vai pra mim portuguesa deve ser
substituída pela pergunta onde está em
caminha portuguesa
se o fizermos mais rapidamente nos
concentramos nos problemas corretos e em
particular dos problemas de quem tem
mais problemas
isto é fundamental mas a mais quanto a
mim é que se melhora o nosso
conhecimento em família
podemos acrescentar às seguintes
perguntas percebeu melhora será que
concentração na solução dos problemas
correntes não nos leva ao melhor caminho
para se conhecer os problemas econômicos
nós temos massa onde pôr as mãos no
presente e caminha depende da análise
daquilo que está acontecendo em manaus
na nós no futuro alinhar com qualquer
ciência social e assim preparar melhor
o futuro para onde vai a economia
portuguesa em conclusão não parece a
minha pronta onde está e paraná e
portuguesa o que é preciso fazer para ir
com a minha pesquisa melhorar
e parece que a minha opção e essa
questão o leva eles seguramente o melhor
conhecimento da economia portuguesa e
fique por aqui
obrigado pela vossa atenção